can we can we really touch something
today mr. camera the question of can we
really touch something is a great one
well let's say we have two electrons I
imagine what we mean by touching is that
they come in and they actually
physically touch now one of the problems
is an electron actually has zero size as
far as we can tell no volume so these
would be infinitely scaled up so how do
the electrons actually interact with
each other
well they interact by exchanging a
particle in the case of the electrons
it's a photon that they exchange so as
they come in a photon is passed from one
to the other which changes the momentum
of both of them and pushes them off so
they never really have to touch in order
to interact with each other to exchange
that particle and therefore change their
momentum and change directions
experience a force so I guess what do we
mean by touching something every time we
touch something we are exchanging force
carrying particles with it and that is
touching if photons are both quanta of
light and the force carriers of the
electromagnetic force does that mean
that photons propagate magnetic fields
and if so why can't these photons be
seen that's because the photons are not
real photons they're virtual now this is
a bit of a problematic topic and one
which I hope to address in detail in a
coming episode the basic idea with
virtual particles is you can't detect
them they're particles that are there
but you cannot directly detect them and
they may not obey all of the laws that
we force real particles to adhere to for
example there's the Einstein energy
momentum relation e squared equals M
naught C squared squared plus P squared
C squared and a virtual particle doesn't
necessarily need to obey this equation
so you can't really detect it because if
you did it would have to be a real
particle and then it can't disobey that
equations like that so this is something
that I will delve into in a future
episode who are your top three most
inspirational scientists I'm going to
take n stein Fineman and Tesla who are
your most inspirational scientists hey
Derek I guess a question that's been on
the minds of a lot of us for a while now
is who would win a chin-up competition
between you and Henry from minutephysics
now I wish this was a hypothetical but
we actually did this on the tube in
London so roll the tape
yeah
nice I thought it would be Henry that
guy's ripped so at school they say atoms
want to have their outermost electron
shells full and will willingly become
ions in order to achieve that
well why and why do the shells have the
electron holding capacity of two eight
18 and 32 and so on specifically let me
deal with the electron shells first see
if you accept that electrons are not
only particles but also waves then if
they are waves bound to a nucleus that
means that they must be standing waves
so you may be used to standing waves on
a string they don't seem to move
anywhere they just wiggle back and forth
or you can have standing waves in two
dimensions on a plate and what you
notice is that these standing waves take
on particular stable patterns so bound
electrons are just standing waves in
three dimensions and the mathematical
solutions are called the spherical
harmonics because of the number of
stable configurations you can have with
growing amounts of angular momentum
there are different amounts of electrons
which can fit into every state that goes
with pallies exclusion principle which
says no two electrons can have the same
state because they're fermions so the
whole point is what we're looking at is
standing electron waves and there are
only certain of them which are stable
which are possible which you can see an
analogy to say vibrations in a plate so
why do atoms want the outer electron
shell to be full well this kind of
minimizes the energy state of the whole
system so let's say you had two atoms if
you actually remove the electron off one
atom and stuck it in the other so that
they both now had full shells you would
find that the total energy is now lower
than it was before when the electrons
were in their previous configurations so
the point is it's just like a ball
rolling down a hill it's that everything
in nature wants to go to the lowest
energy State why are the available
frequencies of light continuous I keep
hearing that atoms absorb and emit
photons of particular frequencies which
correspond to the energy levels of their
electrons so where do all the other
colors come from
okay it's true that atoms emit
particular colours due to electrons
jumping between certain allowed orbits
around them but we get different
frequencies of light when these atoms
bind up into molecules or even solids or
when they form plasmas because then the
charges are flying around all over the
place and in those cases there's no
longer these clearly defined
energy levels for the electrons where
they can jump and only produce certain
distinct colors then they're hold bands
of electron energy levels so we can get
a a real range of colors that's what we
see from the Sun or from hot solids so
that's why we get a continuous range of
frequencies because the electron bands
of energy allow virtually any transition
Derek can I get a veritasium shirt so I
can look nearly as cool as you it's
funny you should mention that gray
because veritasium actually now has a
t-shirt so if you want to get one you
can click on this shirt go ahead click
on it or click on the link in the
description for your viewers interested
in pursuing a science career what field
do you think is going to be the most
exciting in the coming centuries and why
look I can't say I know what fields of
science are going to be important in the
coming centuries but at least in the
coming decades I would put my money on
genetics you know if you think about the
human genome project that took about ten
years and a billion dollars to to
sequence one human genome and within the
next couple of years you should be able
to do it in a week for a hundred bucks
so the pace of growth is simply
extraordinary in that field of science
and that's why if I were going into
science now I might select that kind of
feel have you ever downloaded a book
from audible.com I have actually
downloaded a book from audible.com and I
was listening to it on my most recent
trip which was handy because I was on
this plane that didn't have an
entertainment system and I was also
listening to it in the airport and I
found it really a good way to pass the
time so if you're interested in
downloading audiobooks then you should
probably try audible.com and I have a
book to recommend to you it is Richard
Dawkins book The Selfish Gene I read
this a few years ago and I found it
really enlightening but I have a bit of
a spoiler alert' will not really a
spoiler more of a clarification on the
title I mean it sounds like a book about
a gene for being selfish but that's not
what it's actually about what it's about
is the fact that genes themselves act in
selfish ways and this I found a kind of
enlightening revelation because if the
genes are acting selfishly then the
organism can act altruistically if you
get what I mean
so if you haven't read that book or
listened to it you should definitely
check it out and if you want to download
it for free you can just go to
audible.com/veritasium
you know I really want to thank
audible.com for supporting me and this
my 500,000 subscriber video it really
means a lot to have their support so I
can keep going and hopefully get another
500,000
one last question Derrick I'd like to
know how are buying the laws of physics
you ever managed to put these jeans on